[Music]
Robert James Fisher Bobby more than any
of a single person
he got me interested in chess because in
1972 I was 12 years old Bobby Fischer
played Boris Spassky the World Chess
Championship match and it was front-page
news and chess really kind of swept the
nation and for myself I kind of got
caught up in that bubble of enthusiasm
that brought Bobby brought to chess and
not just that not just the United States
but throughout the entire world so I
started playing chess and you know going
to clubs in Seattle American chess
service and to a coffee shop in Seattle
where everybody played chess in the
coffee shop that was the last exit on
Brooklyn and when Bobby won yay and then
the excitement was building well when's
his next event gosh we can't wait for
Bobby to play again and when's his next
event and so forth and so on and it
seemed like Bobby wasn't playing and he
had said in a lot of his interviews
before he won the World Championship
that he wanted to be a very active world
champion so we were really looking
forward to his play and in 1975 he was
due to play a challenger a challenger
emerged Anatoly Karpov and the
Philippines in that time had offered a
prize fund of 5 million dollars which
for the time was simply huge I don't
know what the inflation-adjusted a mouse
might be but we're probably talking
close to 15
dollars in today's dollars so it was an
extraordinary sum of money and we were
absolutely sure that Bobby would play
that Bobby would win and he didn't and
then over the years it was kind of like
there was this chess parade but we're
missing our leader our cheerleader he
wasn't pulling the parade behind him and
it was kind of like this vacuum like we
were all you know what what what's going
on with Bobby Fischer
what's going on with Bobby the two games
I'm about to show you are to my mind
extraordinary I mean simply astonishing
okay and what this game was was again
let me set it up for you in 1972 Bobby
Fischer beat Boris Spassky became world
champion didn't play another game for 20
years okay now how rusty would you or I
be if we didn't play chess for 20 years
okay this is Game one of that match I
was in Seattle and we were getting this
fax and we just couldn't wait for the
next fax right the ink okay and I get
the telephone reports from George
stefanov itch and in in in Yugoslavia
you know what was going on and it was
like oh it was really exciting so
Bobby's white hasn't played for 20 years
and what we're about to see is a guy who
played perfectly okay every move of this
game is simply excellent like it's too
weird for words right
let me see yeah okay so II 45 Knight f3
knight c6 we all know the Spanish
torture yeah favorite one of the oldest
openings in the world recorded by a
Spanish priest rui lopez and that's
where it gets its name a six more fees
defense the most heavily topical opening
in chess classical defense to 1.e4 and
h3 and here again the major moves or
chigorin's Knight a5 Karpov cites a
variation old classical variation with
Bishop e6 and the Braer variation so the
Braer variation the idea is that this
Knight sits in front of this pawn and
this Knight isn't exactly well placed
because d4 d5 is going to push the night
away and by redeploying his knight the
Knights a little bit more flexible on
the d7 square protects the e5 pawn
blacks intention of course is to
fianchetto his bishop and put pressure
on the e4 pawn the knight on c6 would be
in the way so this is one of the most
popular defenses in chess and it's what
Boris Spassky played as one of his
primary defenses okay so Knight f1 and
the old classical talk talk talk stick
your night on g3 defend pawn on e4 White
has a nice comfortable Center central
advantage g7 g6 all very standard all of
these moves have been seen before
the idea is black takes a 5
square under control just to stop the
night from ever bouncing to f5 Bishop g5
gotta do something
h6 Bishop d2 this move does there's a
little comment because I think everybody
would think that the natural square is
Bishop III but when you put your Bishop
on e3 you're actually blocking your
rooks defense so after Bishop d3 pawn
takes d4 black is threatening efore once
twice thrice you've only defended it
twice you'd end up having to take with
your Bishop on e4 and then after c5 you
have to get up your dark square Bishop
to save pawn on e4 so Bishop d2 Bishop
g7 a4 so one of the ideas one of the
ideas behind this move is to create a
weakness a weak pawn on the b5 square
again all of these moves are very very
standard c5 d5 so now bless you not at
all
White has a nice central clamp in the
position so he's got nice space but
black with his next move plays the move
c4 and it's easy to see that the night
is going to be come to the c5 swear and
it'll be simply excellent on the C 5
squared so you could say that this
position has been seen in chess amongst
top grandmasters many many times and how
to prove an advantage how what will
Bobby do what new concept or will he
undertake well the night is gonna come
to c5 and when the night gets to c5
it'll be so to speak untouchable you
can't drive that night away furthermore
once the knight does get to c5 it kind
of reaches into White's position and
it's a lot of pressure so Bobby plays
the mood before and it's a direct
challenge to his opponent I white have
just taken away the square for your
night what you gonna do about it
okay so Boris decided not unfairly that
the queenside is closed
let's leave it that way since the Queen
side is closed
let me as black prepare the move f7 f5
if black can play the move f7 f5 then
white centre is going to be under
tremendous pressure however is going to
be very awkward for black to play a
fight because at the moment the night on
g3 as well as the bishop on c2 attacks
the square Boris Spassky was criticized
for this move and I think that was an
unfair criticism had Boris played the
move that everybody suggested that he
had to play which was to capture the
pawn on b3 now we see one of the things
that Bobby wanted Bobby wanted to create
a weak pawn here because the Queen side
is going to open up after Bishop takes B
395 sorry Bobby could play in this
position takes variation takes
Bishop c2 and it's not difficult for you
to see that whites and tensions can be
as as clear as Queen e2 rook b1 putting
pressure on this pawn and maybe Bishop
e3 to take this night at a certain
moment as well okay so the pawn on b5
kind of sticks out like a little sore
thumb and Boris Spassky reasoned and I
think fairly that he's happy to keep the
Queen side closed okay so here we are
completely locked up you know like okay
so so what can white do to increase his
advantage
I mean it's not intuitively obvious are
you all familiar with this game because
please raise your hand if you say no
that's okay it's good if you're not
because then I want to quiz you and say
well well what should white do to
increase his advantage what can he do
Queen C ones and the excellent move and
it's a it's one of those moves that sure
after you play Queen c1 you create a
battery you attack the pawn on h6 but
then after h5 obviously you don't want
to lose the pawn what is White's plan
going to be whatever what's going to be
a chain of thought that Y could do in
this position that's a good plan for
white
yeah exactly
okay so that's a nice plan right so the
gentleman suggests what about rook F one
night H two pawn on f2 will come to f4
and to try to attack but we understand
that when we transfer this pawn from f2
to f4 black will capture the pawn and we
have to question ourselves this Bishop
on g7 will come alive and then this
night on d7 which is a little passive
will be given be five squared in other
words we're gonna get something but
we're going to give something to black
as well so the idea of F 2 F 4 comes
into your mind
pardon me yes what the gentleman
suggested Knight H to rook F 1 or Knight
H 2 maybe with the idea of 94 young man
you had a thought to if you were white
what approach would you take you guys oh
you thought of a bad move I do too
ok ok Queen B 1 one of the advantages of
the Queen coming to b1 is it sure is
going to make it really really hard for
for black to play f5 but at the same
time it's sort of like it's not the
nicest way to treat the lady right the
Queen on V 1 is kind of like hidden
behind everything well well we're about
to see unfold before us is its sequence
a chain of moves that is it
it's a beautiful tapestry that Bobbie
weaves he does have an advantage that
the pawn structures of efore d5 gives
him more space than black so black is
friend Bobby played Bishop III Boris
played h5 Queen d2 rook f8
so rather consequent so in the the
battery is created on this diagonal
which has provoked the move h5
but on the other hand we understand what
blacks doing if black has three hands to
do whatever he wants he wants to play
the move h5h for kicking our knight to
another square and then after he's moved
to pawn to h4 he's preparing to play
finally the advance f5 we don't want to
see a situation where our centre
collapses okay kind of light go ahead
execute your threat I'll play rook a3
and the idea behind rook a3 is Bobby
wants to double on the a file take this
pawn on b5 and then invade blacks camp
with rook on a 3-2 a seven-night f6 okay
so what would have happened if Boris had
just pursued his plan if he had gone
straight forward for h4 night f1 f5
takes f5 takes f5 Knight g5 Boris would
have found himself in a bit of trouble
in the first place the pawn is still
pretty good
the knight is threatening to go to e6
furthermore you can't play the move f4
trapping the bishop because this guy
hangs with check after the further move
Bishop to Knight takes bishop takes well
white obviously would like to capture
pawn for free that's one of the nice
things we like to do as grandmasters is
capture pawns for free Bishop f6
stopping that but now Bishop h6 and now
there's a dual threat
I want to play Bishop takes at five so I
can give you a check here but I also
like to capture rooks that are good that
would force Bishop g7 we'd have a trade
and now F for the gentleman had
mentioned F for time ago but now they at
move F for comes with really good
forceful effect before I played the move
F for I had also considered a play the
move Knight to III attacking the pawn
giving black both the option of Queen g5
as well as F 5 F 4 with the move F 4 and
keeping the pawn blockaded so that
Knight f3 is net Knight e3 is next and
if you put this position in the computer
computer will say that white advantage
is quite considerable okay
so Boris didn't do that but he reasoned
appropriately enough that look he black
blacks play on the kingside is not going
away in the meantime what he'll just do
is react to White's idea of seizing the
a file
he played Knight f6 rook a3 Queen d7 and
what Boris's idea was hey listen if you
want to take my pawn take the pawn drop
your rook
I'll just trade off all the rooks and
you haven't done a darn thing you
haven't made any progress rook a -
what's the idea behind that move
yes Alekhine's gun the Alekhine gun
formation is the idea that you want to
double on an open file but now you want
to triple on the open file so your two
rooks act as the barrel and the Queen is
the trigger Alekhine's gun rook a to
rook c8 will understand this move in
just a moment
Queen c1 bishop FA Queen a 128 okay so
the Queen takes up the defense of the
rook on a8 and the game continues Knight
f1 Knight g3 to f1 can somebody tell me
the idea behind that move
that's a thought that the night on g3 is
in the way so it does indeed make the
move G to G for possible in the future
it's another idea behind that please yes
correct
right precisely that's exactly right
so what Bobby's idea is is he sees that
at some moment down the road he is going
to try capture capture everything gets
mightily traded off on the a a eight
square rooks Queens and so on and then
this Knight goes from f1 to d2 to be one
two a three pops out and suddenly you
don't have to defensive the b5 pump whoa
so I mean it's like he what you
maneuvered his knight all the way over
to the Kings side looked like he was
gonna stir up some trouble over there
said okay I'm coming back Bishop e7
Knight d2 King g7 in the meantime Boris
approaches will let me just keep
everything cozy sticks this King Bishop
improves his Bishop a little bit maybe
he's hoping that one day this Bishop
might come around to the b6 square in
the meantime none of whites play on the
Queen side looks especially threatening
night b1 and suddenly there is a very
serious threat there is the threat of a
b a b rook a eight rook e8 rocket queen
a a queen a egg bishop a eight night a
three and there's no defense to this
pawn on d5
how to deal with this threat black could
play the move rook on a a to b8 but
Boris correctly reasoned that after a B
a B rook a7 rook this rook the rook goes
287 this rook goes to a 5 and this
Knight goes to a 3 his queen side is
collapsing so he makes the brave
decision to sacrifice a piece Knight
takes e4 Bishop takes e4 f5 and his idea
is that he's going to get two pawns in
the center at the minimal cost of a
knight but also he's going to get some
very attractive play either based on the
moves ePHI v4 or f5 f4 so what would you
do if you were Bobby where would would
you sacrifice back the peas
the problem is g5 has covered twice at
the moment so he can't go there but we
could do something like 92 pawn takes
Knight takes with the knight idea like
Knight g5 Bobby said ok I'm a piece up
Bishop c2 Bishop takes d5 takes takes
rook a7
mmm now setting up for exactly what you
just mentioned a moment ago Knight g5 is
on white agenda King f6 the sidestep the
Knight g5 threat Knight comes back to d2
Luke takes rook takes rook e8 okay so
blacks idea is okay I've sacrificed a
piece for two ponds but these ponds they
cover a lot of squares and right now
White's
material advantage his extra piece is
not so very meaningful so what should
you do if you were white what you do if
you like
he's already covering
yes Queen a5 is a good move after move
like Queen f5 one thing you have to
consider is Queen a5 a move like g5 with
the idea of g4 trying to press White's
minor pieces backwards another not
inconsiderable idea from blacks point of
view is to play sometimes Bishop c6 with
the idea of d5 as well Bobby played a
remarkable move and I remember at the
time that he was playing it that I
didn't consider this man g4 like Bobby
is a it was a kind of a maximalist
player and from Bobbi's point of view
he's got to make room for his pieces and
the even fit meant weakening his King I
didn't like my god do you know as Bobby
calculated all of this he's looking to
get squares for his pieces g4 hg hg rook
takes a 7 queen takes a 7 f4 okay
so who is benefited the most here from
this advanced g4 is his has white
weakened his King does black have ideas
like Knight g5 so this Bishop if you
stick your Bishop for example on b6
maybe black has ideas for example Bishop
d6 even moves like King e6 Knight f6
ideas what did Bobby play yes your men
see you're playing like Bobby Fischer
and you just got here yeah Bishop takes
f4 Bobby gives back the extra piece
Knight H for this move was a real
surprise to me because I thought that
Bobby wanted to play Queen check King e6
protecting the bishop on d5 and after
Queen check King e6 to recapture the
pawn so he get his pawn back but Bobby
said no no no I want to go after this
pawn which is on this diagonal of the
bishop on C - he played Knight h4 and
suddenly blacks in real real trouble
lots of bad things are happening for
black and you can't play I think I think
he played Bishop f7 yes yeah there was a
there was a reason why he couldn't play
9 f8 and let me just show you that
reason why couldn't Boris Spassky play
Knight I hate young lady
the check yeah and then after this one
so the Queen check was good this was
really good night takes g6 Bravo Bravo
Knight takes g6 the bishop is defended
by the King so now with the move Bishop
f5 check we just drive the King away and
after king f7 well they played Bishop
takes g6 I'm not sure about that
I think Queen takes d5 check and white
has positional domination on all the
light squares right so that peace
sacrifice and the follow-up of g4 Knight
h4 has just been beautiful
so Bishop oh I beg your pardon
so the actual move Boris Spassky played
was Bishop f7 now we have Queen check
King here and now what did Bobby play
previously we had that lovely
combination based on Knight takes g6 and
Bishop f5 now it's not available what
are we gonna do oh I forgot one other
important point gift me your knight
don't blunder your knight I mean it all
goes very very smoothly with the knight
coming to f5 oops
big big big check on the horizon
furthermore if you take it's made in one
the knight is untouchable okay Bishop
has to go back to f8 because the bishop
has to also defend this pawn on d6 as
well as a square g7
being takes ball simple chess with this
move Queen takes f4 you're opening up
the possibility for the night to be on a
beautiful square in the center of the
board where it's nicely protected
Boris played King d7 anticipating the
night check and I came back to d4
checked to White's King King g2 the
bishop on f7 is hanging check Bishop b4
Bishop takes e4 Knight takes e4 here
we'll stop and we'll recognize the
obvious whites pieces of Olga magically
on their very best squares
takk takk takk protected King offside
Knight Bishop rather passive and it's
like wow
you know black didn't make any real
obvious errors but whatever small errors
that black boris spassky is made every
single one of Bobby's moves has been
right on the button
now comes the harvest Knight takes b5
night f8 takes 95-96 queenie fights and
I think that's all she wrote this is a
guy who hadn't played chess in 20 years
comes back and just plays a flawless
game whoa I mean I was just like
flabbergasted i I'm kind of doubtful
that you know like when I sit down today
and I'm an active player that I could
play so accurately and that was that it
really this game almost made me
tearful in the sense my god
if Bobby played this way
after 20 years of doing nothing what
would he have been like if he had
continued to play in his prime in this
peak wouldn't he just you know reset all
the record books ever I mean this was
very very impressive we'll come back for
lecture 2 when we look at game 2
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]